今日はちょっとね一つお話したいことがあるんですよ
あの～僕の動画のいつも最後の方に
エンディングが、流れます
こんな感じ
♪~ED~♪
っっっ
飽きた！
もう、飽きたよ！
もう飽きた！もう飽きた
いつからこのエンディングにしたんだろう
結構、昔だと思うんですけども
YouTubeの動画には何故かエンディングがあるという
この流れがきて
僕も昔からちょっと動画にはエンディングを付けようと思って
エンディングを付けてたんですけど
あの、そろそろもうこのエンディングにも飽きてきました
どれくらいかな？
結構、２年間以上このエンディングでやっているんですけど
いやでも、結構このエンディングに助けられたことも
多いと思います
何かね、面白くない動画も
このエンディングの最後でこう
テキストをバァンって打つことによって
何かうまいことまとまった事もあったので
このエンディングにとても感謝しております
ありがとう！
さすがに２年間もずっとこのエンディングだと
面白くねえと
何か新しいエンディングに変えようかなと思っております！
はじめしゃちょーです！
エンディングか
僕の中の YouTube のエンディングは
これだっ！ってもう決まっちゃってるんで
何か作ろうと思えば作れると思うんでですけども
何かこうぱっと、しないんですよ
ええ、この度皆様に
はじめしゃちょーの新しいエンディングを
考えて頂けられないかと思っております
ああ！無理にとは言わないっすよ！
無理にとは言わないっすよ！
無理にとは言わないですけど
もしね、暇で何か
『仕方ねえな、作ってやるか』
きっ
みたいな人がいたら良かったら作ってみてください！
もう時間がある方でいいので
あのねちょっとね YouTube のエンディングって結構難しくて
長すぎると長すぎるでちょっと
ひゅぅ
画質もねちょっと綺麗な方がいいし
何かこう、皆が覚えやすいような感じのエンディングの方が
やっぱこう、グットなんです！
ひょっとしたら僕がこの２年間使ってきたエンディングは
意外と成功例だったのかなっと思っております
まあそんな難しいエンディングじゃなくてもいいと思うんですけど
それを使うかもしれませんし
それを参考にして
僕が新しく自分でエンディングを作るかもしれない
そこらへんまだ決めてないんですけども
ちょっと動画のエンディングそろそろ変えようかと思ってさ
新年度にもなったし
何だろうな、ポイントをちょっと言っておこう
ポイントとしては
シンプル！
シンプルが大事です！
あと、なるべく短い方がいいかもしれないですね
ほど良い短さです
多分、10秒かな
分かんない！それぐらいかもしれない
後は、BGMとか
うわ、俺分かんない！
ちょっとエンディングってどうやって作るんだ？！
俺自体も、よく分かんない！
でも、大体そんなイメージだと思います！
とりあえずちょっとね、参考にしたいと思ってるので
もし、暇な方いたら良かったら
動画のエンディング、作ってみてください
あ、もちろん、僕以外の人がエンディングに出てきたら
もう、わけ分かんないことになっちゃいますし
ゴリッゴリッの下ネタぶち込むんでも、もう
ひゅぅ
いいエンディングが浮かばないので
ちょっと皆さんの力を借りたいと思っております
多分ね、時間かかっちゃう人もいると思うんで
４月の20日まで募集しております
ひょっとしたらＣＧを使う方もいるかもしれません！
VFX を使う方もいるかもしれない
と言う方がいるとやっぱ動画を作るのに
時間がかかちゃうんで10秒でもね
なのでちょっと時間を長めにとっております
応募して頂いたエンディングは
ひょっとしたらこの動画で使うかもしれません
エンディング発表会ですね
多分、４月中にはエンディング発表会すると思うので
何か、ユニークで面白いエンディングがあると
このチャンネルで発表されるかもしれません
多分エンディング作るような人は多分何かしら動画を作ったことがあると思うので
YouTube のチャンネルを持ってると思います！
なのでその自分のチャンネルにアップロードして下さい
動画の名前は『はじめしゃちょーED』にして
公開か、限定公開にして下さい！
まるで僕がEDになったみたい
で,アップロードした動画のURLを
下の応募フォームから応募してください
ニックネーム、チャンネル名が僕のチャンネルで
紹介されるかもしれません
これもう多分ね、
質問コーナーに近いような企画だと思ってます
多分まともなの作ってくれる人いたら嬉しいですけど
ほぼね、何かねド下ネタとか、
わけ分かんないヤツが来るかもしんないので
そこもちょっと楽しみです！
はい、という訳ではじめちゃちょーのエンディングを考えようの企画です！
もし、動画作りに自信ある方
このエンディングおすすめだよ！ってある方
下の応募フォームから応募して見て下さい
なかなか今のエンディングが板についてるから
なかなか難しいと思うんですけど
良かったら是非、作ってみて下さい
とびっきりのド下ネタ！
綺麗なエンディングをお待ちしております！
じゃなあ！